all right we are talking with Amanda in
Florida her son came home from college
during Kovac and had changed his
attitudes to a point of disrespect to
the point that they asked him to not
stay with them anymore he does however
still work for his dad's company and
that's about how far we got in the
discussion a lot of pain a lot of things
going on and Amanda then you were
getting ready to pose your question and
we ran into a commercial break so how
can we help so he's working for my
husband um he's decided that you know
this is what he wants to do for a living
it's a block construction block company
and so he's dropped out of school and we
told him from the beginning that if you
because we gave him several
opportunities to say you know is to make
sure this is what he wanted to do but he
has to pay us back for school if he
messes it up like if he does things that
he you know and so my as he's working
for my husband we've asked him to move
out he's moved in with his girlfriend's
family we've told him he has to pay us
back $1,000 a month and he's making good
money I guess my question is is that
reasonable we told him if he decides
he's not paying us back then he no
longer has a job with my husband and
again this is all stuff I never thought
I'd have to deal with and I'm just
trying to of course I feel guilty that
we've kicked him out but I know we
needed to it's just all this I don't
know I'm not I mean I think I'm just
wanting some confirmations or correction
whichever yeah it sounds like there's a
couple of things going on here one is on
a high-five you for you and your husband
get on the same page and setting
boundaries whatever those happen to be
and of those are hard especially when it
comes to that moment you look your son
who's 21 on one hand and who's still
what like three right you still remember
those days and um you're still got a
three-year-old there too and that
doesn't that's not easy and so I wanna
high-five you guys for doing the hard
right loving thing the second thing is
before we get into the nitty-gritty
about the the stipulations you put on
him financially and and you know his
work is I want to encourage you and your
husband to
what I would say get off site which is
you know that's a business term for
y'all go get breakfast and sit down
together and grieve the loss of the
picture that you had in your head that
was when our sons 21 and then say that
that picture refer right now looks
different and then say here's the new
one
and what happens off and his folks just
move right into the next thing they race
into it they to quote the language we
use here they stay gazelle in tents and
they never stop to transition from one
picture to the next and it just adds
weight and pain to all the conversation
discussions and it just makes things
cloudy and messy and then so when it
comes to the comes to the the financial
thing here's my thing I've worked with
so many 19 20 21 year-olds thousands
over the years and I would really
challenge you all if you and your
husband are together y'all are united to
give him a moment and I get the dollars
and cents and Dave I'd love to hear your
perspective as a guy who's parented
older kids I haven't - to a young my
guess is he's gonna he's gonna circle
back around and my guess is that he is
in a season he's in a moment and he's
testing boundaries he's seeing how much
I love him how much you care about him
and my opinion is putting a dollar
amount on it right this second when
things are hot and things are painful
that may not be that that's going to
give him fuel to a punitive fire versus
a wheel of you fire that said your
boundaries are your boundaries and you
get to decide what those are and I just
my opinion Dave is I wouldn't bring
money into this conversation like you
owe us now doesn't seem like the right
moment to be having that conversation
how much how much money as we interview
for well honestly like we 20,000 okay
then what's your house I mean what's
your house holding so let mine and my
husband's um probably just under a
hundred okay and then you're wanting to
add what you're asking what from from
Adam we're asking him for a thousand
dollars a month no you were just about
to add another some more information
yeah okay so
to John's point what you're trying to do
in your it's a struggle for in these
high-stress situations to maintain it
you're trying to help him that's the
goal your your reason for doing all of
this is is 5% self-protection and I
demand anyone in my presence to have
reasonable respect for me that's a
normal that but 5% of this is that 95
percent of this is you know the way he's
acting is not good for him and you're
trying to help him adjust his behavior
so the 30 year old him is a better him
agreed true and so the way I would ask
myself the question is not do a holdfast
to this particular rule of the money I
would ask whether forgiving that money
or waiting a little bit to collect that
money or being hardcore to collect that
money now which one of those things
brings him to where you want him to be
because this is about you still
parenting him that's really what it
amounts to and that's a reasonable thing
so if I love someone I'm trying to do
what's best for them so which you have
one tool left in your hands you have two
tools the debt and the job these are the
two points of leverage you have with him
how can we best use those two points of
leverage to get him to ultimately be a
good a person that he's gonna like and
that he's gonna want to be later because
that's all we're trying to do as parents
we're just trying to get to turn them
into humans you know and turn them into
good you turn them into good humans and
right now you got one with a mouth on
him mm-hmm yep yeah in that what I've
seen parents do is get into a tug of war
and then eventually you get to a place
where a line is drawn so deeply that
there's no coming back from it and a 21
year old whose brain is still developing
who's still getting a lot of outside
info from his buddies and from social
media and from other nonsense crosses a
line that it's hard for them whether
it's ashame wise or whether they end up
lying to the people who love them the
most are stealing from those who love
them the most they end up in a place
that it's hard for them to will ever
walk back from
and so like Dave said I would challenge
you guys to play a 20-year game a ten
year game versus a I want him to pay a
living with his girlfriend tax or would
your husband do that to another employee
who worked for him right would hold
those same outside the now I was on that
side of it from a family business
perspective he cannot work there unless
he is doing the job and having the same
level of respect as other employees are
expected yeah he's an employee yeah he
can't bring his freakin little 21 year
old mouth to work with him mm-hmm
because I'll fire his little butt for
that in a heartbeat I would but you're
gonna you're gonna you know you're gonna
act like I'm the CEO because by god I am
at work and you're gonna act like you're
an employee because you are and that
that's not that's not a boundary I'm
willing to negotiate on because you're
gonna create a toxic work environment
for the rest of the team there does your
family drama is now playing out in your
husband's business bad plan do not allow
that to happen but as long as he's
respectful at work gets his work done
keeps his nose clean so to speak then
then you can play games with the money
stuff and other otherwise you know you
mean you can decide to be hardcore
forgive it completely or delay it or
whatever anywhere in there but what gets
you to where you want to be what has the
most likelihood of him turning the
corner what causes that grace or rules
sometimes its rules and sometimes its
grace you just got to make that call
prayerfully and John John's suggestion
you guys getting off site and kind of
unpacking this rather than calling all
the plays in the huddle real time is is
really wise because it's really really
easy when you are parenting teenagers to
call all your plays in the huddle which
can cause damage to that teenager
because because parents lose it so Dave
we we did you and your family decide
we're gonna be on stay at home
conversation or a hard hard conversation
about here's what I'm dad here's an
employer Oh
yeah as soon as they started talking
about working here we had we wear
different hats I think that's an
important line to draw your kids you've
heard them rent Rachel Daniel Denise all
haven't called me Dave in the office
this weekend at the lake house Papa Dave
that's intentionality right absolutely
very very clear I'm a CEO here I'm
grandpa this weekend beautiful this is
the Dave Ramsey show